Brian and Meg are with us hey guys my
name how's it going doing great thank
you so much for having us absolutely
welcome to Nashville where you all from
oh cool cool so you picked a weird day
to come to Nashville not so bad we're
kind of used to driving in this stuff it
was everybody else on the road yeah
that's generally the truth right there
so um did you guys drive down yes sir
what is that about five hours about five
hours is so bad we're used to driving to
her parents who live in Dallas so that's
about 11 hours Oh where's the rest of it
this is my oh this is easy it's nothing
yeah so you're here to do your debt-free
scream how much have you paid off
$28,000 in 12 months
way to go making what kind of money
about $80,000 good what do you guys do
for a living well I'm a friend developer
for a company called spry digital and
st. Louis and I am an office manager for
a child not a lesson psychiatrist very
cool good for you guys so what kind of
debt was just 28 thousand student loans
and credit cards not evenly sporadic yes
okay I don't know Magda why you said
that it kind of sounded like it was
yours
she had the credit card debt and I had
the student loan so I came in with more
credit card debt than he had student
loan oh okay
how much credit card debt it was about
$18,000 of credit card debt came in so
you just got married we got married May
of 2014
right and then you started this route
about the UM a little bit afterwards so
we found out during our premarital
counseling that money was going to be an
issue for us we both came into the
marriage with money issues and the
person we worked with really helped
bring that out it was like six months of
doing nothing like knowing that it was a
problem from our weddings and then
finally we just we're completely
resigned to the fact that we had to do
something and I just looked at Brian one
day it was like we have to take FPO
we have to take how did you know about
Financial Peace University my friend
Abbi introduced us to you and her and
her husband escolar still working the
baby steps but we heard about you about
four years ago years ago so we knew of
you we just hadn't been compelled to
take any
okay so the pre marriage counselor says
trouble spot danger warning warning
warning so we get married we get home
the dust settles and then it comes up
you go oh he was right yeah we started
trying to look at our money and things
like that and every time we talked about
finances I end up curled up in a ball
crying and so I think he was right when
he said so what happened when you went
to Financial Peace University tell me
about the process everything changed it
took us about the three months like you
said to really get that budget set it
took us a little bit you know Brian was
freelancing at this point I was working
retail and it just took us a while to
kind of figure it out
especially with our fluctuating income
and then also we added some budget line
items and things like it just took us a
while to make it our own and then once
we finished with FPA we were just so
encouraged and we just ran with it and
we just said this is going to happen we
have to have this happen so you started
getting enough power that you know you
could do it exactly there was a light at
the end the tunnel that's not a train
yeah yeah the hardest part for me was
getting traction because you know you
start off and it's so difficult to
change how you've been doing things do
things differently take suggestion and
just stick with it until it starts
working yeah when I'm learning something
new often could just get mad yes makes
me mad well the funny thing is that when
we heard about you initially you know
Brian bought Total Money Makeover and I
read it and I stopped every time I'd
pick up that book and I got to the debt
chapter and I almost I threw it across
the room a couple times like I was just
like there's no hope you know I just
completely hopeless and financial peace
gave us you know the language and the
tools to use and gave us that common
language you know so I could express
things that I didn't know how to express
before you know someone financial peace
you talked about the security gland and
Brian was freelancing and I was just you
know I was so scared
you know and I didn't know how to say
that before I'm scared I'm scared you
know that by saying my security glands
really going right now we were able to
actually work through that
so it was really cool so thank you so
much you're welcome I'm honored to walk
with you guys I can tell from listening
to your story sometimes people have more
of a dramatic change than others and you
all had a real metamorphosis you had a
complete change really good and how you
look at this whole thing you now are
telling money what to do it used to tell
you what to do 100% correct yeah Wow
Chris so you've gone from this you know
crisis minded world to now dreaming
what are these financial talks look like
now oh my goodness we want to go you
know how much to say this month as
opposed to do you want to do something
fun with it yeah so it was really cool
because this is our first vacation not
to my parents house pretty much the
whole time we've been together you know
honestly we didn't do a honeymoon
because our we barely were able to pay
for the wedding and our plan was at the
one-year mark to go on this big
elaborate trip to Europe and then
reality hit an FPU hit and we realized
that we weren't gonna be able to do that
and now you know we're hoping to go to
Orlando in May because that was the deal
I made yeah but yeah that was part of
the deal as if I could get debt-free I
wanted to do a debt-free scream in
Orlando I don't work and now we can do
that yep and it'll be the follow-up to
the one here exactly this is not exactly
Disneyland or Disney World but close but
if I can make a plug your entree
leadership totally saved our bacon we
learned I had learned a ton that helped
me in my freelancing stuff and it's
still like my playbook that I refer to
today
well thank you I even used it to vet my
current employer I use your hiring steps
in Reverse that's good doing that that's
very good very nice well you guys are on
fire you're fun congratulations I'm very
proud of you really done cool stuff your
family's got to be looking at you going
yeah yeah and that was the coolest thing
is that when we told our families like
kind of what we were doing you know we
have such supportive friends and family
they said you know if that's what you
want to do that's what we're gonna
support and it's just been unbelievable
they've been so understanding so awesome
so cool
aiwei I'll take my coverage so one last
thing before we do our stream how did it
feel emotionally when you got all those
cards out and you cut them up it was um
it was cleansing I mean I don't even
know it's like sucking the poison out of
your system you know it hurts so much
but then at the end of it you're just
like oh my gosh I can breathe I couldn't
believe it I wouldn't cut my credit
cards did you have five five okay no I
was thinking more okay good I had three
of them one of them had a more than
$10,000 limit they were all maxed out
when we we finally did this oh very cool
good for you thank you don't done y'all
all right Brian and Meg st. Louis
Missouri $28,000 paid off in 12 months
making $80,000 a year count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one
awesome man that is amazing well done
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show I want to write a song I want
to own my own business I want to make
more money
those aren't goals those are wishes my
New Year's resolution is to make more
money this year to wish